thanks for staying back and
i know it's hard to stay back this late
on friday evening um so
i was wondering whether is it bad to
give a talk late talk on friday evening
or first stop and saturday morning i
don't know so
we'll see we'll be tomorrow's morning
attendance
um so so this is joint work with mark
rodelson and adam smith
um this will cover a couple of papers
that we had on this topic
um
so let's start by describing uh the
standard setting in database privacy so
we have a database d
and
we want to release some function f on
this database privately the the question
uh that we're going to ask in this
answer try to answer this talk is how
much distortion is needed to release fft
to guarantee the privacy of these
entries
and we have seen in this workshop so far
that we have made huge progress in this
both upper and lower bounds on really on
this understanding this problem and
in this paper in this talk we're going
to try to understand it from a slightly
different perspective so we are not
going to restrict ourselves to
differential privacy but we are going to
ask this under a very loose notion of
privacy
okay and the way we are going to say
something is non-private is by
understanding uh
a required station attack
so what's the reconstruction attack so
let's say that we want uh some function
f to be evaluated on this database
and there's a private algorithm that
sits and says that it releases f of d
plus some noise
we will say the reconstruction attacks
for an adversary would succeed if if
that was you can construct a d hat which
is a good approximation of v
okay
um the reason is that since if you can
make if you can reconstruct almost all
of the database
then it should be obvious that it
doesn't it's not a good notion of
privacy under any any notion of privacy
so it's so recursion recursion attack
implies a lower bond for any reasonable
motion up price it's so it's so these
low bonds are much stronger than just
for differential privacy
uh so this is going to be the talk
summary so i'm going to show that you
can
use linear reconstruction techniques
in surprisingly many settings and i mean
i think most of these things was even
surprising to us because many of the
functions that we're going to analyze
that don't even look linear in any way
so some like logistic regression or m
estimators
but surprisingly you can use a simple
technique or linear reconstruction that
would work for all these problems
um so the attack would work under for
all these problem but the analysis
of these attacks would be done under
some distribution assumption of the data
so we're going to assume the data from
iid to analyze
to get the lower bounds
okay so so one of the themes that been
established over the last decade ever
since uh the seminal paper of denura
nissim is that
privacy requires
distortion okay um in fact it's i mean
do you know anything show that if you
answer
too many
uh
queries uh
too accurately i mean they use upset
some queries
then uh there is an adversary who can
reconstruct the database almost entirely
and so this is fairly well understood
now um
so just for concrete as let me just talk
about a couple of slides about the new
sim attack
to set the ground um so here's the
setting in that was analyzed in the
neural netim and also in many of the
follow-up papers so we have n users and
each user is supposed to have a secret
bit which is zero one
and then we have
we need to uh we have say let's say we
want to see in a product query with this
x so we have some vector s
and we want to compute this inner
product of s with x
okay um
so let's say there is a private
algorithm that's that computes these
inner products and releases f of x plus
some noise
uh and let's say that we don't release
one such query but we will release m
such queries so so we we have s1 s2 sm
and for each of these
uh vectors we release
uh this f of sx plus noise
okay and and the goal of the adversity
is that given these m releases two is to
construct an x hat which is a good
approximation of
um so
denote nsm showed that informally that i
mean this is informal statement that if
uh if m is order of n
uh so if you have n such releases and
each release has at most order of square
root of noise so the amount of noise
that you add for each answer
is
order of little of square root of n
sorry uh then there is an adversary who
can reconstruct
almost the entire database
so you can construct one minus the lower
front fraction of the database
so that that's
very well understood and they've been
actually tremendous work in this area
following that paper so the questions
have been asked about what is a good set
of
uh what are the what are the different
subsets what are the different uh
ways of say creating these ss
there have been papers on understanding
the number of queries the trade-off
video number of queries and the running
time of algorithms and so on
uh so in a product queries are nice but
they are not very natural so
uh so what we have been trying to do is
to understand linear reconstruction
attacks
to obtain privacy bonds for natural and
symmetric queries
so in a couple of papers we have shown
that many uh
i mean natural functions could be
could are
could be analyzed using linear
reconstruction attacks so we have looked
at
uh marginal contingency tables
and also
recently we looked at uh some regression
analysis boolean function releasing
boolean functions and so on
so that's going to be the
the talk that i'm going to cover now
um so
let's unders so what's a linear
reconstruction problem so it's a fairly
very well understood and fairly simple
problem so given a vector z
uh which is some ax plus e where a is
some real real matrix and e is some
unknown noise vector the question is can
you consider x hat which is good
approximation of x
so so z is uh so x is some secret
vector
a some real value matrix e is some
unknown noise vector and given z you
want to construct x which is a good
approximation of x
uh this problem is actually comes in
almost like in machine a lot of in lots
of area like machine learning image and
so on and the natural approach for
solving this is
look at some lp nominalization of this
so you take a z minus ax put some p now
standardly standard you put p equal to 2
r1
and when you have p equal to 2 you this
is known as least squared method
and p equal 1 it's becomes a linear
program so it's called lpd coding
uh just one slide about least squares
attack so so if you want to say minimize
this problem
um
if
one of the the simplest way would be to
take a singularity composition of this
matrix a
that's u sigma v transpose
and then define a pseudo inverse of a
and then define x hat as a inverse z
rounded to close to zero one so i was
assuming the data is boolean so you just
round uh take a university and this just
round them either if it's greater than
half pick it one less than half make it
zero
and this if uh and this attack would
work actually i mean this is this least
square attack would work actually and
this is the standard way of
how denude and same analyze their attack
also and following works
uh the
the the thing that
needs that's needed
on a to make this attack work is that
the least singular value of a is
sufficiently high
so i think it's
so what you need is that the
a is an m cross n matrix what you need
is that the least single value should be
at least the square root of the number
of rows in the matrix
so that's square root of n
so if that condition is satisfied a
satisfies that condition
then if you do this this simple attack
you have a x that is going to be one
minus little one fraction away from x
this is assuming uh
something about the error all right
uh
yeah so they're assuming the error is uh
square root of n a little of square root
of 1 yeah you're right yeah that's
um so again so as i said so so linear
reconstruction could be done using
either p equal to two so either you look
at put a two norm on the z minus ax or
one norm
and
they both lead to a different style of
attack so least squares or lp decoding
uh lp recording attacks are stronger in
that you can tolerate a much bigger
error
so you can have a gamma fraction of
entries to be arbitrarily large and this
was shown by a work of dark mercury and
talwar
of how to analyze these attacks and then
but
what you need is a stronger condition on
a and it's also costly to run because
you you are solving a linear program now
so
for lpd coding you need a strong
condition on a
but uh it gives a strong better bond
you can tolerate more noise
yeah um
so with that uh let me describe our
setting that we're going to uh
use that we're going to describe to use
analyze contingency tables um so we have
a database d
with n rows and d plus one columns
uh the users are represented along the
rows of the matr of the table and the
columns are the attributes
okay
and what you're going to assume is that
among these d plus one columns the first
d columns are
uh non-sensitive attributes
okay so when i say something is
non-sensitive i'm meaning that it's
unknown to that adversary so it's those
are kind of public information
and the the last column
uh we'll assume it to be sensitive
information for the user
so that's uh not known to adversity i
mean that's what adversity is trying to
infer from the release
so for example it's known that ali is
smokes but it's we don't know whether
she has high blood pressure
um
so
so how do you launch a reconstruction
tag if you have marginals um
so let's take the simplest case of uh
marginals and that's that's simplest
marginal that you can think of as a
two-way marginal
uh so basically what you're trying to do
is you're trying to release
uh inner products between the columns
of this of this matrix
okay so two way marginals
uh say let's say you want to listen to a
margin between a one and x that's just
the inner product between a1 and x
so let's say that if you if you get
really if you release all these two-way
marginals
so all the two-way marginal speed in x
and
columns of
of a1 to ad
so you get all these results
okay so now the attack is fairly simple
what you do is
you just put your uh ace in the
you you know all your a's you just stack
them along the rows of the matrix a1
transposes the rows of the matrix a1
transpose a to transpose and ad
transfers
you're basically transposing the matrix
and just multiplying them so now
this ax is same as
these results
and notice that
a is public information because we
assume that a1 to ad is known
that's that's fairly simple right i mean
so you you have this setup where you
uh
your a is known you you have you get
your noisy releases of z
and
you're trying to in for x
you put p equal to two or one and solve
for uh either least squares method or
lpd coding and you get your x hat
okay that's that's very well understood
so now the same thing works for like if
you're thinking of a three-way marginal
so what the a nice way of writing a
three-way marginal is like you see if
you have
three-way margins between a1 a2 and x
you can think of them as being a
um hadamard product between a1 and a2
and then in a product with x
satellite is just an entrywise product
so you're just multiplying the bits
entry wise
so if you do this that's the three-way
marginal between a1 a2 and x
okay so though now with three all the
three if you release all the three
modules you are getting all these
uh entries so even e to x a 1 a 3 x and
so on
so now how do you construct a you just
do the same thing you just put instead
of a 1 transpose you put a 1
a 2 even atomized product a 2 transpose
as and these these are the rows of this
matrix so now if you look at uh the
matrix a
in this case the matrix a was a a d
cross n matrix
right because there are there are d
columns now it's a d cross d square
or d g cross n matrix so now we are
increasing the size of there
but you have more more releases
uh
yeah you need uh
order of yeah uh d choose two i mean you
need a d square you don't need all of
them but you do
yeah you don't need all the d2s too but
you need an order of theta of d square
actually
uh and so so that that's the tax that's
that's basically the entire
reconstruction attack so and this this
will generalize for higher margins also
instead of that this thing something
else will come up
but they all look the same
um so how do you analyze these attacks
though
the analysis is a little complicated and
that requires you to analyze the
spectrum
uh so okay the first thing is that
we assume that uh entries are id now so
what you do is that we assumed all these
ais are going to be iid um
and so once you do that things become
much simpler at least you can analyze
you think that thinking about you start
thinking about analyzing these attacks
uh
and so
and so let's say the one of the key
elements is that if you have for this
for three-way marginals is that if if
your ais are all id random vectors
and some d satisfy some condition then
um
the least single value of this matrix is
at least omega d again so what we needed
was the leasing value should be square
root of this number of rows in this
matrix let's say there are d choose two
rows and you get omega of d
uh the analysis is a little complicated
because even though your ai's small ai's
are
iid vectors you are adding correlations
by taking these hadamard product so the
now the rows are all correlated
and the lemma extends to k plus and
marginals also
so you now you have d choose k
number of rows and your uh
leasing value of this matrix would be
at least
square root of d power k
and so
so this is this is the final theorem i
mean if you uh use this uh analysis is
that uh if algorithm releases all the k
plus marginals with
square root of d power k or square root
of noise
minimum of this then you can then there
exists an adversary which can
reconstruct excite with
uh having distance between x and x being
little of n so they address you can
recover one minus low and fraction of x
um
so that's marginal tables
uh
and this was with just the least squares
attack and in fact you can get a
stronger statement if you use instead of
l2 in an l1 attack so use a linear
program
uh and maybe you know i'm not that
surprisingly this
this could be also extended to any other
boolean function not just conjunctions
uh and this this basically depends on
the fact that volume functions could be
represented as a multi-linear polynomial
using standard fourier decomposition
uh
so just a quick definition uh
we look at boolean functions
on k variables and we call it a new is
non-degenerate if it can be represented
as a multi-linear polynomial of degree
exactly k
okay so every boolean function of with k
variables could be represented you see
as a multi-linear polynomial of degree
at most k but where we focus on exactly
k
and almost all the interesting building
functions that you can think of except
hunters fall under this
and rx or majority decision trees and so
on
um
so
i mean so what what does you mean by you
are evaluating a boolean function on
this on this on this database
so remember what we're doing for
three-way modules words we are looking
at a specific function which is this uh
and function so we are taking uh
when you're doing this we are looking at
the just multiplying all the bits okay
but you can think of replacing this and
function by any other function any
boolean function so you can now for a
general function f you can say that
instead of releasing this and function i
can i'm going to release these and i'm
going to sum up all for all the rows and
release the final sum
so that's what uh releasing a boolean
function on a table means uh so now the
adversary instead of getting the
distorted
uh
entries like these will get in our
distorted functions which will depend on
the small f
and again it's not
too surprising because if you can do for
conjunction it's probably true that you
can do for all of the functions because
it's one of the
is kind of the like the prototypical
function for boolean variables
um
and what we show is that that holes uh
you get the same kind of results so the
the the noise that's needed is exactly
identical as in the case of conjunctions
or marginals
and yeah this was for uh k equal to
three but the same thing works for more
variables
yeah i'm going to
yes uh well yeah for for a general k
that would be a square root of d power k
so
uh one thing i need to say is that uh
the analysis actually works for k equal
to constant i mean we don't know how to
do it for
k as a function of d also n
and that's because we don't know how to
analyze the spectrum of random matrices
when k is not constant
um
so i'm going to uh like in last five
minutes i'm going to switch gears and
talk about
uh how these linear reconstruction could
be
uh used for obtaining lower bonds for
releasing m estimators and we have so on
we have seen a couple of talks on m
estimators and uh erms
and predicts talkers about arms um so
so just a definition slider just to say
the notation uh so let's say we have n
data points like uh x1 to xn
and
let's say we want to fit a parameter
theta to these data points so
and the way we are going to fit the vc
how good theta is to represent x i is
using the sum logs function okay so the
loss function will define how good a fit
theta is to x i
um
so concretely think of this as being uh
so if you want to solve you can think of
solving some uh
l2 square problem so your you have
n points
and i want to find f theta which is
which is going to minimize this l2
square distance
that's an error
or you can replace it by one norm so in
this case you know i mean the standard
thing is that this is this theta is the
mean of these endpoints in this case the
theta would be the median of endpoints
in general you can define for any loss
functions and so you're trying to solve
this problem so you have endpoints
and you're finding the theta that's
that's going to minimize the sum of
these loss functions
um and if the loss function is
differentiable the the way to solve it
is to take the gradient and uh and set
it to zero
ah so i'm just going to say quickly
about how things can be extended to
logistic regression so
uh
so logistic regression in logistic
regression we are trying to fit uh
you're looking at the logits
of these uh of these independent
variables
and you have expressing it as a linear
function of independent variables
um so they have the
think of dependent variable as being the
x and independent variables has been the
columns of
this a1 to ad
so
so the a logic a logistic regression in
this the simplest way would be to say
this you look at these logic bits
and you're saying that uh
and you're saying that
expressing that as a linear combination
of these columns of ai's
um
so here i'm going to take things for
granted it's getting late uh
so
if if you do the math uh the standard
way would be to like i mean if you want
to find theta the the the best the way
would be to take the maximum likelihood
estimator of
of these uh
of these functions
and take the gradient of the maximum
likelihood estimator and set it to zero
and if you do the math this is how it
looks like you can take this for granted
um so you'll have some so this is the
function this is the logistic regression
between fitting a i and x together so
you're
so you'll have dependence on ai x and
theta hat is the
logistic regression parameter
so as you see i mean though the function
may not look like linear but i mean it
does some linear thing but the in enough
things don't look like linear but
you're already starting looking some
linear patterns that's coming up
and so so what you do is just
so you have this
uh
so from ai from for the first release
you can get this
the first release is like this so you if
you have d such releases what is that
you do is you stack all of them together
okay so you just start putting them
together so this is you get these
this from the second release a3 is
things from the third release and so on
and so now what you see is that
if you look at uh the the product of
these two
it's independent of x it's some constant
because you know the ai's so it's
constant constant b and you have some
matrix a which is again the transpose of
the
non-sensitive information and times x
so suddenly again so it's again in
linear form
so we have a linear system of the form
ax plus b equal to zero
uh and there are slight technical issues
here is that you don't release you don't
actually get x you don't you you are
getting is what you're getting is the m
estimators so the estimators of theta
hats
and not the noisy version of this vector
but you need to do some work to show
that the function since the functions
are lipschitz
uh you can overcome that
and
and you get this result
so
so what is what is it says is that
uh again uh if you have uh
an algorithm that releases the
parameters of logic segregation between
the columns a1 to 80 and x
and say let's say d is at least 2 n i
mean
then you need to add one plus square
root of a noise to each parameter
and again this is uh
very significant noise in this setting
because you're thinking about a
small number
okay and again you one can do a better
attack using an l1d coating
um
then the nice thing is that uh this
thing actually works for any
differentiable an estimator so if you
have the function as long as the
function as long as function
differentiable and the ellipses constant
of the function of the gradient actually
is small
this attack would work
um
yeah so so so wrapping up so what we
show is that
we can use linear recursion attack to
prove privacy lower bonds
for a very
like natural and very broad class of
functions which including boolean
functions m estimators
um and these bonds are actually tight
for under this loose notion of privacy i
mean a simple sampling argument would
show that uh you can you need at least
square root of n
if you get you square root of a noise is
suffices for upper bounds
because you can just sample n by two
columns and by two rows and
uh
work with them
without the public information
but if i just uh let's say i want to
release uh
two-way
conjunctions uh let's say in the
products i can just take uh i just
sample half the rows
of this matrix and throw throughout the
remaining half the rows and just release
my two a products inner products on
those that part of the matrix and it
will be square with if you
will be still only square root of n away
from the actual answer
whereas we wanted to recover one minute
loan fraction of this so in that case
you'll only require at most half the
entries
since
um
so a couple of open questions that
remain from this uh line of work is uh
uh these low bounds only seem to work
at least the the analysis
and this kind of a technical question is
that it works only for differentiable
estimators
so we don't know how to do that for
non-differential range tomatoes so stuff
like median we don't have to do it yet
uh but we know how i mean it's easy to
extend these two for example if you have
say a ridge regression or something so
if you have a regularization parameter
in front of this
uh linear regression thing it's still
possible but we don't have as long as
the function is differentiable so we
don't know if if the function is not
differentiable the loss function is not
differentiable we don't know how to do
it
and i think something more uh
like something more philosophical is
that we have
we have attacks and i think all the
texts that we know
are all of the linear form so
you get some y equal ax plus e and
you're trying to solve x hat
um do non-linear attacks help us in any
way
i don't know
thank you
um
maybe
one thing you can do is you can extract
linear
inequalities right uh by using the sub
gradients instead of the set of sub
groups but then you get somewhat
and the issue is that uh depending on
how big this set of sub-gradients you
get some some some sub so some are
sub-gradients
right so
there's enough uncertainty in the
sub-gradient that
that there might be you know so there's
that that creates some
uncertainty and the problem is if you if
you convolve with a smooth kernel or
something you're like you're changing
the problem that might not be the thing
that
you were given the
minimizer limit like
no no but here like some well okay we
can talk about it basically i i'm not i
don't think
at least
naively it doesn't work
straightforwardly doesn't work but maybe
maybe this
more questions